[Music]
after Watson and Crick came up with
their hypothesis regarding the structure
of DNA the scientific world was now
curious to know how it could be
replicated they put forth a hypothesis
that the DNA replicates in a semi
conservative manner that is both strands
separate and each serves as a template
for the synthesis of new strands
template in literal terms means a
pattern used as a sample to make
something however the scientific world
was not ready to accept this fact easily
so there were three theories put forth
which hinted at the replication process
of the DNA double helix one was called
the conservative model the other was the
dispersive model and the last was the
semi conservative model let's first
understand what each method had to say
the first model in the list is the
conservative model this model suggested
that two DNA strands separate and serve
as templates for replication
but soon after replication the strands
joined back to form the original parent
DNA while the new synthesized strands
joined to form a completely new DNA does
we get a newly synthesized DNA molecule
and we also get the original parent DNA
molecule back which is conserved hence
the name conservative replication now
comes the next one this was called the
dispersive model of replication as the
name suggests dispersive means to
disperse or scatter so what gets
dispersed well according to this model
the DNA which is about to replicate
breaks into small fragments the new
strands get synthesized in between as a
result we get a hybrid of both new and
old strands together the old parental
strands appear to be dispersed in the
newly synthesized one hence this method
is named as dispersive
now comes the last model it was called
the semiconservative model of
replication the model suggested that two
strands of DNA unwind and serve as
templates for newer strands as a result
the replicated DNA's contained one old
and one new strand hence the name
semiconservative nevertheless this model
was not accepted initially when put
forth by Watson and Crick however one of
the most amazing experiments in biology
named the meselson and stahl experiment
helped crack this mystery to geneticists
Matthew meselson and Franklin Stahl
carried out an experiment around 1958
they used a heavy isotope of nitrogen
and inserted it in the DNA of the
bacterium Escherichia coli they obtained
several generations of e.coli and
analyzed each for the presence of DNA
the results helped them understand that
the replication of DNA in e.coli is
indeed semiconservative this is how DNA
replication takes place in almost all
organisms now let me introduce you to
one more interesting term it's called
the central dogma never heard of this
well it's an important term and an
equally interesting concept in biology
this central dogma in molecular biology
is used to explain the flow of genetic
information and what does that mean we
all know that DNA governs life but any
idea how this mechanism works let's
understand this with the help of the
central dogma in a Cell the DNA from the
nucleus replicates to make a copy of
itself this is that we're aware of and
do we know what the functional segment
of DNA is it's a gene it's the segment
of DNA that codes for a particular
character the part of DNA
which acts as a gene gets copied in the
form of a single strand this is called M
RNA this M RNA that is the messenger RNA
to be precise is a single strand copy of
the DNA it comes out of the nucleus in
the cytoplasm and then is worked upon by
the special machinery of enzymes the
enzyme machinery reads the code hidden
in the mRNA and synthesizes proteins
accordingly this complete process of
mRNA synthesis from the DNA followed by
the synthesis of proteins from the mRNA
is called as central dogma in other
words this simplest process by which
proteins are synthesized from the code
of the DNA molecule is the central dogma
of life this is how it's usually
summarized did you know that these two
steps have a scientific name the process
in which the mRNA is synthesized from
the DNA strand is called transcription
and the process in which proteins are
synthesized from the code of mRNA is
called translation would you want to
know more about these interesting
processes for that unit to our upcoming
videos
[Music]